well today marks four weeks can you
believe it since clark county lifted all
its coven 19 restrictions
but with cases of the new delta variant
rising health officials are increasing
vaccination efforts
with several pop-up and walk-in clinics
right now our bianca holman is live at
one of those spots at charleston and
maryland parkway bianca
yeah there was a steady flow of people
here at the fire station
four getting their copin 19 vaccine most
in and out in less than 30 minutes and
there are three other clinics happening
today as well
the biggest concern right now is the
spread of the delta variant it makes up
almost
50 percent of new infections in nevada
doctors say your best defense is to get
vaccinated which is 95 percent effective
and there are no excuses for you not to
get one all pharmacies have the vaccine
and there are numerous pop-up clinics
being set up in various neighborhoods
the las vegas fire and rescue says that
they're here to help the community
one of the things the fire department
has always done is community outreach
and prevention
i mean it's prevention is is one of the
things that the main thing that the fire
department does even though we responded
and reacted last year to the pandemic
this year
we're now that the pandemic's winding
down we're responding to prevent this
upcoming flu season
now here at this location the johnson
johnson vaccine is available as well as
the first and second dose of pfizer
i'm told about three quarters of people
coming for the fire
vaccine are actually on their second
dose so again this clinic will run
tomorrow from 9 00 a.m to noon
as well and then there are also a
vaccine clinic at palo verde high school
as well as west prep academy
and that will run until six and then
there's one at la benita supermarket on
cheyenne and jones and that is until
nine and again we have all this
information listed on our website at
8newsnow.com reporting bianca holman
8 news now bianca thank you and a
reminder if you get at least one dose of
the vaccine you will be entered to win
five million dollars worth of prizes you
can win other things
like state park permits fishing licenses
even that grand prize of a million bucks
the raffle starts thursday july 8th and
runs through the end
of august